wow this is really bright
hi everyone to follow boobs and fart
jokes and SNL basically my name is Amber
Hameed I'm the VP of information systems
at Dollar Shave Club I wanted to thank
everyone here who's attending in the
audience I think this is a great support
mechanism for us women up here telling
our stories
I want to thank hustle for arranging
this this amazing venue and having us up
here this is a great opportunity and I'm
in great company of some fantastic women
and their storytelling when I was
thinking about what to talk about I was
giving it you know I was bouncing a lot
of different story ideas off the wall
and and I thought that you know I got
here but I didn't get here alone so my
story is not just mine it's a story a
lot of other people who contributed to
where I am today and I wanted to pick a
handful of those stories of people who
contributed to my life and the success
of my career and I wanted to give them a
shout out and tell my story through them
these are people who sacrifice their
lives their future their people who made
sure that I got that opportunity that
showcase my skill these are people who
put aside their preconceived notions
about whatever culture and biases to
make sure that you know I got that I
made the cut and I got that opportunity
and there were people who just showed up
imagine growing up in a country where
women don't get a lot of opportunities
and most importantly growing up you know
in an environment where you are barely
educated a single mom with four
daughters and your entire inspiration is
to make sure that your your daughters
get the best and the highest of
education that money can buy
this story is about four women who were
highly educated in a third world country
one of them ended up being a master's in
psychology another one ended up being a
gynecologist one of them ended up being
dinner masters in fine arts and another
one was the principal a very coveted
school that woman was my grandmother and
the woman who got me here to where I am
today is my mother and when we got here
she brought two suitcases and three kids
in tow as a single mom and she made sure
that her children had the best of
opportunities that she could afford I'm
very lucky to be part of that legacy and
I'm very lucky to be here because of her
and when I came here all she said to me
is you know what I can give you is a
shot at a good life and a good
opportunity and the rest is up to you
that wasn't too long ago and when I look
back at it all I can say it thanks mom
for giving up your entire life your
family your comfort zone to make sure I
got here the second person I'd like to
talk about and there's one more thing
she said to me she's like you know
you'll do well because I raised you like
a son and not like a daughter and if you
know where I come from that's a huge
compliment cuz it is all about sons and
guns where I come from so it's
interesting that you know the biggest
mentor the first mentor in my life was
this woman called Paula when I grew up
in Pakistan where I'm from it's almost
kind of a coming-of-age story you get
your nose pierced you know you turn 16
you go over and you get your nose
pierced an exciting thing to do it means
something completely different obviously
in the u.s. it's rebellion you know it's
it's kind of going out there and making
a mark you know and my first opportunity
out of college for a young student was a
coveted internship at a pretty big
employment company in Boston called the
gillette company it's amazing how you
come full circle and i was in college
and i was you know doing four jobs to
make ends meet and go to college and pay
my way through it and you know i was
told that my nose ring would be an
impediment to me getting this internship
and the reason i knew this
I didn't know at the time is that I
showed up to the interview I did my
interview and Paula who was my boss and
mentor my first female boss my first
ever female boss she looked at me and
she said by the way I just wanted to let
you know you have the job I have a bunch
of students sitting out there who are
you know I have to go through the
rigmarole and interview them because
they here and they showed up but I just
wanted to let you have the job and I
also wanted to let you know that your
student counselor in your cover letter
that he sent me told me that you were a
nose ring and that might be an
impediment to the Gillette culture he
said I want you to go back and tell him
that I gave you this job despite but
notes ringing us so thank you Paula for
giving me that shot that shot that made
me never look back the third story is
about Tony hey Tony is interesting we
used to call him the billion dollar boy
he wasn't going his entire life this is
it a consult to come be there worked at
was contributing to the consulting
company in the bandwidth his entire
personal network is what brought almost
a billion dollars worth of business to
the consulting company and it was a good
idea to be in his good graces now Tony
is this big burly Italian guy you know
you can cast him in any Tarantino movies
you know for coppola movies and this was
during the time when nobody was hiring
consultants people were letting go and
it was to 2018
I'm so sorry 2008 and lived in New York
and right across the street from me was
the Lehman Brothers office everything
was pretty much going downhill at that
point and you know he called me into his
office and you know he looked at me and
said I'm gonna make you an offer you
couldn't refuse and I said what is the
Tony and he said I have a little bit of
budget and I have an opportunity in
which you will be working with two of
the biggest software giants and I want
you to spearhead a practice for this
consulting company like okay why me and
he said because I know you'll get it
done and I'm gonna give you one resource
and the rest is up to you to go figure
it out and not only did I manage to
get that going I was able to showcase
that all over the world from the
platform of this consulting company all
over Europe
we won almost 17 million dollars worth
of business off of this prototype that
we built and it was something that was
actually showcased at both of the
software giant's major events as a
cut-through a breakthrough for them in
both events and this all started with
two people and this was a shot and a
flavor of entrepreneurship that I got
and it was extremely exciting for me and
that propelled my career in all kinds of
different directions and one of the
reasons why I'm standing here today and
the last story that would have
technically tell is something about my
own unconscious bias during one of my
most thrilling career opportunities but
very stressful career opportunities I
was in dire straits this project that I
was on was gravely behind schedule and I
was really looking for for a data Talent
and as most of you in the tech industry
know that's hard to come about and this
was in New York and being behind
schedule drastically was a huge
challenge for me so I needed somebody to
come in and hit the ground running and
you know really do a good job and I'd
already gone through about three
different data architects and I was
having no success so finally I had this
woman walk through my door and as she
was coming in you know I realized she
was eight months pregnant and she was
looking for a job that would keep her
local because she was having a child and
she wanted to start a family and she
didn't want to travel anymore and I
needed somebody who can hit the ground
running and if you're at once pregnant I
knew she was gonna be going on maternity
leave very soon so I started
interviewing her and she knocked it out
of the park she was exactly what I
wanted and I looked her in the eye and I
said and I couldn't ask her about a
pregnancy obviously but I said you know
this is what I'm looking for I need
somebody to be here you know this is an
opportunity that I just can't afford to
lose again
and she looked at me and she said I'm
having a c-section I have three kids I
know what I need to do I know what I'm
going in I know when I'm coming out I'm
going in December fourth I'll be showing
up January fourth and the other person
who was sitting next to me is another
woman another mother and she looked at
me she says no way she's throwing up
it's not happening
after c-section and delivering a child
is no way and lo and behold she showed
up
January 4th she was there and she was
one of the cornerstones of the
successful project that I did so thanks
Louie for showing up an inclusion I also
want to talk about people who didn't
show up and you know who those people
are you know you are I don't want to
take it means they're people who didn't
show up the naysayers the dream
Snatchers the ones who always told me I
would never amount to anything and
there's a lot of them there are a lot of
people who told me basically that I
wouldn't succeed because I wasn't ready
I would like to thank them because they
made me work twice as hard
they made me more determined than ever
they made me work harder and better and
it made me show up and all I have to say
to them is how do you like me now thank
you very much